most of the 800,000 federal workers who
were not paid during the partial
government shutdown are starting to
receive back pay but there are
potentially millions of government
contractors who may never see a dime ed
O'Keefe met with some of them he's at
the Smithsonian's National Air and Space
Museum in Washington which reopened this
week ed good morning good morning John
well we talked about government
contractors folks might think it's IT
specialist so the folks that helped
build the lunar landing here behind me
in reality most of them are like the
folks that cook in the kitchens here at
the museum clean the bathrooms or
provide security at Smithsonian museums
and other federal buildings across the
country and unfortunately for them the
prospect of getting any back pay after
the recent shutdown is slim it's really
hard the government shutdown isn't over
for a single mom low niece Hamilton I'm
definitely scared of being evicted I'm
scared of my car be repo scared of my
life's getting turned off scared of my
gas getting turned off and scared she
won't see any back pay for four weeks of
missed work at the Smithsonian's Air and
Space Museum a security guard Hamilton
protects government buildings but as a
contractor she doesn't feel the
government is there to protect her it's
really stressful not knowing where my
money is coming from not knowing what
when I'm gonna be able to buy my son his
next meal told she makes too much income
for food stamps Hamilton says she can't
afford to buy the lunch her
five-year-old likes to take to school
he's kind of sad about that he doesn't
get the things that he used to get
meanwhile nearly 1500 miles away near
the Mexican border another government
contractor Kevin Doyle also is
struggling to feed his children we went
through the car and found all the chains
we had I went in the seats trying to
find out how much money we had to our
name which was nothing at the time but
we scraped up three dollars and 89 cents
for a happy meal for my four-year-old
and we both sat there and cried in the
parking lot of McDonald's he had issues
paying for her recent doctor's visit and
couldn't afford his mortgage or his
oldest daughter's college tuition when
he came down to not be able to provide
for your children that day was the most
heartbreaking day I've ever had
still Doyle quit
his job as a contract encryption
specialist for the airforce as soon as
we got the notice that everything was
opening back up and we were not gonna be
paid I'm like I can't do this no more
this is it I'm done today he's starting
a new job as a contractor in the private
sector but it comes with a pay cut more
than $30,000 they want to bicker
somewhere else in Washington DC or
elsewhere you know we don't we shouldn't
be held accountable for their actions
now dozens of Democrats in Congress
agree this bill is about simple justice
Connecticut Senator Richard Blumenthal
is backing a bill that would provide
back pay to low-wage contractors and how
on earth do we pay for this we have to
take it as one of the costs of that
shutdown which could well have been
avoided if the President had simply come
to his senses a little bit earlier by
one estimate 3.7 million people work for
the government as contractors doing 200
million dollars worth of work each week
but that no longer includes Kevin Doyle
they mentioned 800,000 workers but they
never mentioned the contractors that
work in and around them and that's not
fair
now that bill that senator Blumenthal is
sponsoring doesn't have any Republican
co-sponsor right now but he said he's
hopeful that the issue of back pay for
low-wage contractors might come up
during the negotiations that lawmakers
are having right now to avoid yet
another shutdown which by the way if
they can't find an agreement starts two
weeks from today
John Edie thank you it is an outrage
great work I think Kevin Doyle really
encapsulated what it is not only that
the fear that you have about not being
able to provide for your family but the
pain yeah no one working for the US
government should be desperately
searching for change to buy a happy meal
for their child in the car and this is
the most basic thing in government can
do which is it's meet its minimum
requirements for keeping the lights on
and paying the people it's promised to
pay yes okay